[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS WILSON: Hi.
I'm Chris Wilson.
I'm a Developer Advocate
on the Chrome team.
JAN LINDEN: And I'm
Jan Linden.
I'm a Product Manager
on the Chrome team.
CHRIS WILSON: And we're here
to update you with where we
are with Web Audio and some of
the exciting things that have
been happening there lately.
I wanted to start by showing
a few demos that I've been
building over the past few
months and we'll get into some
of the new features
from there.
So let's go take a look
at my computer here.
And you can see I have
this web page up.
It's webaudiodemos.appspot.com.
This is kind of where
I dump everything.
So it doesn't mean it's polished
or finished or great,
but it's usually pretty
interesting at least.
And probably the most exciting
thing since the last time we
talked, back in August, was
we have live input now.
Like we can get a live audio
input into the web platform.
So you may remember I did this
net little Vocoder application
that takes a sound, takes a
voice or any other sound, and
Vocodes it.
So you should be hearing,
hopefully, some--
[COMPUTERIZED VOICE]
CHRIS WILSON: There we go.
And I built this back for Google
I/O before we had live
audio input.
But the process it's going
through, this Vocoding process
of analyzing frequency bands
and applying those to a
different sound over time, it
actually works in real time.
All of this is happening
in real time.
So when we finally got live
input working, it actually
took me all of about half an
hour to get it up and running
on the Vocoder.
I just had to put in a little
button to turn it on.
And of course, we have to ask
if it's OK if we use your
microphone because we don't want
people spying on you or
listening in on you.
But once you do that, you can
actually hear that I'm talking
into this and--
let's crank the gain up.
It's a little weak here.
There we go.
And now, I can just give my
entire talk in the Vocoder for
the rest of the time.
And mess around with
the pitch.
JAN LINDEN: Please don't.
CHRIS WILSON: Oh, OK.
All right.
I've been told that's not a good
idea, so we'll skip that.
But kind of neat for the Vocoder
but this also means
it's quite easy to build
other applications.
The next thing that I did was
immediately took a bunch of
the effects that we'd been
talking about, just things
like delay and reverb and
that sort of thing.
And made an application that
lets you switch between them
so you can hear what
they sound like.
You can apply different
effects.
It's a little zoomed in here.
And this also meant that I could
start playing with more
complex effects, things like
flanging or chorusing.
And these effects actually take
a fair amount of plugging
together of audio nodes
and doing some
tricks with audio params.
And there's also my personal
favorite, the octave doubler
effect where you can
hear a sub-octave.
And which is an effect Chris
Rogers developed.
[COMPUTERIZED VOICE]
CHRIS WILSON: But this also
means you can do things like
audio recording directly.
So I threw this app together.
All it does is show a frequency
analysis of the
current audio input.
But at any point in time,
I can just say, I
want to start recording.
So I click Record and I get
a little red button.
And then when I'm done
recording, I can see a
waveform analysis.
And I can download it to my
machine immediately and then I
have a wave file.
I can play back the wave file--
Recording.
So I click record
and I get a--
and you can tell it's
recorded the bit of
sound that I had there.
This is a very, very small
chunk of code.
All these, by the way, are up
on GitHub so you can go grab
the code and play around with
them and look at them.
JAN LINDEN: So Chris, can you
explain how you record to disc
because that's actually
something that people have a
lot of questions about--
CHRIS WILSON: Yes it is.
JAN LINDEN: --how to do that.
CHRIS WILSON: So this is an
interesting one because this
is actually taking several
different pieces of code,
several different library
functions and
plugging them together.
The first one, of course, is
just grabbing user media.
So getting a live input and
pulling it into an audio node,
doing a frequency
analyzer on it.
So I draw my own little
frequency analyzer at the top
of the screen that I pulled
from some other code.
I wrote a library that does the
audio buffer display at
the bottom.
But the real time recording part
is actually done using a
JavaScript node.
And the JavaScript node
basically just sits there and
collects buffers and stacks
them together.
And then when I say that I want
to download it, there's
actually a function in this
library that will encode that.
This is a library called
Recorderjs
that's also up on GitHub.
It's pointed to from my
repository for this app too.
So you can go find it
and play with it.
It only encodes into
wave file format.
It doesn't do compression.
It doesn't try to do bit
reduction or anything fancy to
try to get it into an MP3 file
or an Ogg Vorbis format or
something and do a little
bit better than that.
That will come, I'm sure, but
it's going to take a little
bit of time to do good encoding
in JavaScript.
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
We can actually--
we'll talk about that a little
bit later when we come to some
of the new stuff coming
in web audio API.
But when offline mode
is coming that
will help in order--
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
JAN LINDEN: --to do
these things.
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
Yeah.
This was an interesting
experiment, mostly because I
got to play around with moving
audio buffers around and
actually grabbing the bits out
of them and sticking them
together and that sort of thing,
which I hadn't really
played with much before.
And let's see.
That kind of gives you a good
idea of what you can do with
live input.
The only other one that I
added live input to--
and this was actually
the first one-- is
apparently not there.
Never mind.
So I'll fix that after the show
and you can check out the
pitch detection.
But basically just doing
analysis on an input and I
actually used a real time
analyzer to do that instead of
a JavaScript node.
Although, it's a very, very
naive pitch detector.
It's not something you
should really use.
It can barely tune my
guitar into tune.
Although, it does pretty
well with whistling,
which was kind of cool.
Apparently, I picked the right
test sample the first time
when I wrote it.
But I wanted to talk too, in
general today, just about some
of the more advanced uses of web
audio that are starting to
solidify now that we've got a
pretty mature implementation.
And we've been working through
a lot of the issues.
For example, the chorus and
flanging effect that I have in
the live input demo.
I originally wrote the chorus
and flange for Google I/O, and
then I had to pull it out at the
last minute because I was
sitting there like a week and
a half before the show
wondering why my code wasn't
working, why I wasn't getting
a chorusing effect.
And finally, I went to Chris and
asked him to take a look
at my code and he dug through
it and he was like, huh, oh
yeah, we have a bug here.
In the interim, it got fixed
so my code just kind of
started working and I had
another input effect.
But when you start plugging all
of these things together,
you can see sort of the power
of what you can do with the
Web Audio API.
And I started saying, one of
the things that I really
wanted to-- the reason that I
really got into Web Audio was
I was interested in
synthesizers.
I've always had a passion
for synthesizers.
And so I started building
a synthesizer.
This is kind of loosely based
on the Moog Prodigy
synthesizer architecture.
It's not like a direct copy.
It's not a re-creation.
So don't rip on it too much
from that perspective.
But I wanted to give something
where you could actually play
notes in it and you could
control a bunch of different
parameters.
So you can [INAUDIBLE]
filter and cut off and
things like that.
And all of the modulation
effects and those sorts of
things work.
And I actually had a ton
of fun building this.
It took me about a week
from beginning to end
to build this sample.
And the interesting bit to me
was most of the time, actually
like 90% of the work that I did
here, 80-90%, was all user
experience.
The Web Audio part was actually
very, very small.
It was a small chunk of figuring
out how to do a
volume envelope the right way
and figuring out how to
connect the modulators
and things like that.
JAN LINDEN: Did you have to make
any JavaScript nodes for
any special stuff?
CHRIS WILSON: I did
not actually.
JAN LINDEN: You can do
everything in Web Audio
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHRIS WILSON: You know, I think
the only application
that I built thus far that I had
to use a JavaScript node
for was the audio recorder
because it really needs every
bit, like it needs every
piece of information
that goes past it.
The pitch detector, really if
I wanted to do super high
quality pitch detection, I
might switch over to a
JavaScript processor.
But there is some latency
because going into the
JavaScript process is going
to introduce latency and
imprecision.
But I thought this
was a ton of fun.
But of course, the interesting
bit of Web Audio is how
programmable it is, how much
you can play with it.
And I wanted to point out one
thing that I did was, after I
built this, I realized I spent
all this time building the
user experience and all these
knobs are just jQuery knob UI.
I didn't like hand code all
of the UI and you can tell
there's still some little bits
that don't look great.
But I realized that one of the
parts I spent a bunch of time
on was just a voice architecture
for a synthesizer
and building the keyboard
and making it so you
can play it on screen.
You can play it using the
computer keyboard.
I have it plugged in with the
MIDI polyfill so I can play it
with a little keyboard
that I have standing
over to the side here.
It's off-screen.
And then I can actually play it
and it sounds more like I'm
actually playing music.
But I wrapped all that code
together and I have the super
simple version of this, the
template for a synthesizer,
which you'll notice all
of the UI is missing.
And you can still play
it the same way.
But the interesting bit about
this one, is you can go in and
grab the code.
And it just has a voice object
type and when a voice is
created, when I call new voice
every time, a new note gets
played, then it pulls in and we
have code right here that
can figure out what the
frequency needs to be.
JAN LINDEN: Can you bump
the font up just one?
CHRIS WILSON: Sure.
Let me pump it way up.
Obviously, I was in deep
programming mode yesterday and
had it down a little bit.
You can grab the frequency for
the note and then you just
create an oscillator
in this case.
Or maybe you want to grab an
audio buffer and figure out
what playback rate
to set for it.
But in this particular case, all
that I have is a sine wave
oscillator and then I create a
pretty standard attack, decay,
sustain, release envelope
for it.
And then at the end,
I call note on.
And that's it.
There's no other processing in
this particular synthesizer.
It's a pretty straightforward
one.
But if I wanted to make this a
sample playback synth instead
of creating an oscillator, I'd
create an audio buffer source
node connected to an audio
buffer, figure out what the
right playback rate was to get
it to play back at the right
frequency, and you're
off and running.
So you can grab this synth
template, plug your own code
into the note on and note off
parts, and really easily get
up and running and have
something that's playable and
usable without having to go
build the actual onscreen code
and stuff like that.
JAN LINDEN: Wow.
Nice.
CHRIS WILSON: And of course, the
other bit that I probably
ought to mention is I've been
working on making sure that
that works well on
iOS as well.
I've got my iPad here.
I have the same page up and
running and you can probably
hear it now.
It plays the same way.
So I put touch support into it
as well so you can get some
effects there, get some
additional device support.
In fact, I think one of the
interesting things to me too
is seeing how touch and mobile
devices is going to affect Web
Audio as it rolls into there.
The iOS implementation
is really good.
It has some parts of it that are
still pretty challenging.
I was talking with Jan right
before this about convolver
node is still pretty
iffy on iOS.
I ran into some problems because
I was using it for
reverb on the synthesizer.
But a lot of other apps are
really easy to build, and the
responsiveness of
having a touch
interface is pretty cool.
I have one app in here that
is called Touchpad.
It's really kind of like my
first mobile audio demo.
All it does is it plays a sound
when you touch and as
you move around, it changes
filter parameters.
So it changes the filter
cutoff frequencies.
You drag down and it changes
the Q values.
You drag across.
So you can kind of close the
filter and open it back up.
And you can whirl around.
I'm just going to carry
this around with me
when I go out at night.
JAN LINDEN: [? You can annoy ?]
[? anyone. ?]
CHRIS WILSON: Soundtrack.
Soundtrack.
Yeah.
JAN LINDEN: Excellent.
CHRIS WILSON: So Yeah.
I think one of the great things
to me is we're really
getting to the point--
I've been seeing a lot of other
people's applications
come out with Web Audio, in
Web Audio 2, and some
interesting new things.
There's like Pedalboard.js,
for example, that does a
framework for building effects,
effects chains, and
pedal boards, really.
It's kind of cool.
JAN LINDEN: So you can just
hook up your guitar and--
CHRIS WILSON: You can hook
up your guitar and go.
Yeah.
I really should have brought my
guitar with me but then I'd
have to play it on camera and
that would've been kind of
embarrassing.
But just plug in my guitar.
I actually have a guitar--
I used to have a guitar in my
office all the time and then I
didn't for a long time.
And now I've brought my electric
guitar into work and
it sits there all the time, just
to plug into Web Audio
and play around with it.
Because sitting there and
playing through all of these
live input effects with an
instrument is pretty cool,
even cooler than doing
the voice and things.
JAN LINDEN: We should maybe talk
a little bit about on the
input on the latency
that you get.
CHRIS WILSON: Definitely yes.
Yes.
So one of the things that has
really been a goal then for
the whole time has been
super low latency.
That was one of the things that
I know it was frustrating
to me for a long time because I
really wanted live input but
the engineering team, and
Chris in particular, was
really passionate about having
super low latency, like
musically useful audio input,
rather than just something
that you can get audio input but
you might have a lag time
of over 10 milliseconds or 20
milliseconds or things that
aren't super useful when you're
trying to play a guitar
through it.
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
I actually did some measurements
recently and you
can get down to five
milliseconds from microphone
in to speaker out, with pretty
standard hardware.
And if you just use your Mac
without any USB device or
anything, you can--
on my Mac, I got it to
nine milliseconds.
CHRIS WILSON: That's
pretty good.
JAN LINDEN: That's
very useful.
I mean it's like having
a speaker nine
feet away from you.
CHRIS WILSON: Right.
JAN LINDEN: That's
very manageable.
CHRIS WILSON: It's really nice
to have such good feedback and
such low latency and be able to
do something that's, like I
said, musically useful.
That's one of the exciting
things to me has been just
working with such a low latency
API, although it ends
up bringing up new challenges
too and you have to come up
with new architectures.
Like one of the things that I've
been talking with people
a lot about lately has been
the concept of scheduling.
And scheduling musical notes as
well as Web Audio and then,
of course, web MIDI
events as well.
And the idea of how you would go
about building a system so
that you sort of schedule ahead
on the high precision
timer because you don't have
events in the Web Audio space,
in the Web Audio time
I should say.
Like you can't say, call me back
at precisely this number
of microseconds, basically,
because JavaScript doesn't
have that kind of level of
precision in its eventing
system either.
So you have to sit there and
say, you know what, I'm going
to set an interval timer and
every 30 milliseconds I'm
going to call back, or even
less than that, every 15
milliseconds, which JavaScript
can usually handle, I'm going
to go play the next 20
milliseconds of events and set
them up in the Web Audio
event queue, or
the MIDI event queue.
I think those sorts of
architectures are still coming
and I'm working on a demo for
that but I don't quite
have it done yet.
JAN LINDEN: Since you mentioned
MIDI, I know another
very passionate thing for you
is to get the APIs for that.
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
Yes.
Yeah, so MIDI is sort of the way
that you hook up musical
instruments, controllers.
I have a whole pile
of controllers
on my desk at work.
People always stop by and say,
what do you do here anyway?
It's because I have all these
weird things sitting there.
And it's also used for things
like lighting systems and
other things as well.
But it's not just I have this
professional synthesizer that
I want to connect anymore.
And to me, when I first started
looking at Web Audio
here, the thing that immediately
was obvious to me
was that it was super
powerful.
You could create these really
rich musical applications
except the inputs were still
like go click on something
with a mouse or go drag
this slider and I was
like, that's horrible.
I can't stand it.
I like having physical things to
touch and move around, and
knobs and buttons and things.
And MIDI is the way
to do that.
So I immediately said, OK, how
do we go about adding MIDI to
the web platform.
And I became the co-editor
of the specification.
We now are in our second
public draft.
It's getting pretty stable.
We've still got a few open
issues but we did bounce at
zero issues for awhile there.
And we're looking to get some
native implementation.
But I also wrote a polyfill for
it that uses a plug-in on
OS X and Windows.
And the plug-in basically allows
you to include this
JavaScript library and then just
act as if the web MIDI
API is there.
So you can listen
for MIDI events.
You can grab on to different
devices, send MIDI outputs if
you want, that sort of thing.
So it really helps unlock the
power of Web Audio to me,
particularly with things
like the synthesizer.
I mean, it's really hard, even
with the computer keyboard,
which is a physical button, to
play anything that's really
expressive.
But of course, I can play it
pretty expressively on my
keyboard here.
And because this was a
replication of an old analog
synth, it didn't have a ton of
controllers or anything.
I haven't yet done things like
velocity responsiveness and
the controller responses
and that sort of thing.
I have some of the
things hooked up.
You could tell.
You can play with the filters
in real time,
that sort of thing.
Yeah so that's kind of the
lap around the newer
stuff that we have.
JAN LINDEN: So let's talk
a little bit about
what's coming up next.
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
JAN LINDEN: So a few things I'm
aware of is the engineers
are working on an offline mode,
which means that you can
do processing not in real time,
faster than real time if
you want to or sometimes slower
than real time if it's
really complex.
And that, as we mentioned, will
help you in doing, for
example, encoding before
you dump something.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
It's also nice for when you're
building digital audio
workstation type software
because you can apply an
effect and then just grab the
audio buffer if you want to
save it and not have to try to
do everything in real time.
JAN LINDEN: Yep.
That's a nice one.
CHRIS WILSON: I saw that there
had been a sort of trial
implementation of that under
the covers in Chrome for
awhile, but Chris added that to
the Web Audio specification
too so you can read up on
how to do it and go
play with it in Chrome.
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
And there is a new spec
coming out pretty
soon, I think as well.
And then the other big thing and
the input is part of this,
so input is done by hooking up
to the get user media, which
is part of the WebRTC efforts,
and there is a lot of effort
going on to hook up WebRTC and
Web Audio in other ways so you
can actually take the input or
the output from a Web Audio
and connect that to WebRTC and
then, for example, if you have
a video conference going on,
then you can apply all these
cool effects and then
send it over there.
And likewise, the next step is
on the receiving side, then
you can do the same thing or do
analysis or do spatial or
whatever you want to do on
the receiving things.
CHRIS WILSON: For a while, I've
wanted the ability to
just hack into my Hangout and
apply Web Audio effects, if
for no other reason than
taking that dynamics
compressor and applying it to
everyone in the room because
I'm on a lot of teleconferences
with people
from different locations and
invariably half of the group
is in a conference room
somewhere and they're very
quiet and you have to listen,
crank your volume up, and then
there's the one guy who's
sitting with a microphone
right on his lips and jumps in
and blasts everybody out.
JAN LINDEN: Yep.
CHRIS WILSON: It would be nice
to kind of tone that down just
a little bit.
But yeah, it's going to
be really exciting.
I can't wait to sort
of start applying--
doing all my Hangouts
in Vocoder mode
or things like that.
That would be kind of cool.
JAN LINDEN: Great.
CHRIS WILSON: So
yeah, I think--
did we have any questions to
answer from the queue?
I can't remember.
One second.
[SYNTHESIZER PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: So we
do have a couple
questions on the moderator.
So let's go ahead and
get ready for those.
One of them asked about
performance.
How much will the difference in
implementation on different
operating systems make?
For example, a tablet
or smartphone.
And then second, obviously some
operations require more
power than others.
What are the dangers in the
current implementations?
CHRIS WILSON: Good,
good questions.
Yes.
So of course, there are going
to be differences in
performance on different
pieces of hardware.
We see that today.
Even depending on what audio
hardware you have, you can get
different latency, particularly,
but even so,
you'll see a difference in
processing if you have to do a
lot of conversions for buffers
and things like that.
JAN LINDEN: You'll really have
to optimize hard to get it to
run well on the mobile
processes, for example.
And that's definitely room
for improvement there.
As you mentioned,
the convolver--
CHRIS WILSON: Of course.
JAN LINDEN: --node is not quite
working as you would
like it to on iOS yet.
But the combination of faster
processes coming out there and
more optimization will
see that improve.
But it's definitely a very
important thing and today, it
won't run perfectly
on every scenario.
CHRIS WILSON: No.
No, of course not.
JAN LINDEN: And then operating
system also has an impact,
like doing things in Mac and
Windows is slightly different
and there are things
that can be done.
Typically, we get better
performance on Mac but still
really good on Windows,
especially when we can use
certain modes there.
And then Linux is obviously a
little bit more spread in what
you can get.
CHRIS WILSON: Of course.
And mobile as well.
The spread in hardware in mobile
is just so broad, even
outside of Web Audio,
of course.
JAN LINDEN: But the basic
effects that you really need
for doing gaming, et cetera,
if you don't want to go too
far, you should be able
to do a lot of that.
CHRIS WILSON: One of the
things that has been
fascinating to me to understand
has been one of the
big values of Web Audio is
simply cracking apart that
process of downloading,
decoding, and playing audio
files because with the HTML5
audio element, that's all
wrapped together.
Like you can play separately
but it's not--
JAN LINDEN: You can't
really do anything--
CHRIS WILSON: --really
a low latency play.
And the download and decode
is all wrapped together.
And at least you can crack those
apart and just the value
of being able to control
when those steps
happen is pretty important.
And then, when you're building
gaming or even just like
interactive sound for an
application, making little
beeps and boops when you roll
over things or select
different options or whatever,
that's actually really
lightweight in terms of what
you're doing with Web Audio
but it's very effective in terms
of giving feedback to
the user and having a more
immersive experience.
Then there's, of course, the
whole processing pipeline and
even doing some basic effects
can be pretty easy.
But once you start trying to
really crank out a lot of
nodes together--
I was kind of fascinated that
Vocoder actually worked when I
first implemented it, because
when that's running in real
time, it has about 400 audio
nodes of various kinds active
all the time and processing all
the time, which I was sure
it was just going
to fall over.
But it was doing OK except every
once in a while as I was
practicing my I/O slide deck,
I would discover that it
wasn't working quite as
well as I thought.
It sounded a little noisy.
It wasn't really glitching
but it was kind of
crackling or something.
And then I realized that I was
using the speaker notes mode
and it was actually
instantiating it twice.
And it only happened when I was
like triggering it from
the MIDI keyboard that it was
running both of them at once.
But it was basically setting up
800 nodes and running them
all at once on my poor
little MacBook Air.
JAN LINDEN: So you
still have to be
careful what you're doing.
CHRIS WILSON: You still have
to be pretty careful what
you're doing.
But I think for a lot of the
basic things, it's actually
not that complex.
And if you look at things like
the synthesizer that I built,
for example, it's actually not
doing a lot with audio nodes.
It is doing some pretty
solid processing.
I need to go back and play with
it more in iOS now that
I've sort of narrowed down that
the convolver is causing
a challenge for us.
But I think that, in general,
you'll see performance will
continue to improve and
be easier to manage.
On the power issue, power to me
is really very related, in
this case, to performance
and memory
usage as well, of course.
But I think that the fewer nodes
you can get away with,
the more lightweight you can
make your application, the
better you're going to be.
But I don't think you're
going to see some kind
of huge power drain.
JAN LINDEN: No.
And when you look at these
devices, typically nothing
gets close in power consumption
to the display and
everything so--
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
JAN LINDEN: --it very often
drowns in that.
But of course, if you're running
at full speed for a
long time, that will have
an effect on power.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So our next question.
Jeff wants to know, how he can
make simple onsite effects,
for example, distortion or
pitch with only one user
adjustable parameter that the
user could activate for
streaming music on the site.
And in terms of page load speed,
what would be the best
practice for doing this?
CHRIS WILSON: One effect
with one parameter.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So apply one effect to
some music that's
playing on your site.
And what would be the best way
to go about doing that?
CHRIS WILSON: OK.
Applying one effect at a time
and giving a small set of
parameters, it's kind of similar
to the audio input
effects demo that I built which
I've meant to come back
to and make it a little more
componentized, but I think
that it's a pretty good example
of how to plug in a
single effect and let you
play around with a
parameter or two.
The one challenge is music
playing back on the site.
If you don't control the site,
even if you can inject
JavaScript, you can't always
grab control, like grab that
audio stream.
You can't grab an audio
stream off of a
Flash object, for example.
JAN LINDEN: But if
it's playing in
an HTML5 audio tag--
CHRIS WILSON: Or even a video
tag you can then--
JAN LINDEN: --then you can just
use that as an input node
to Web Audio and then you can do
whatever you want with it.
CHRIS WILSON: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
And Lincoln from Miami wants
to know, he'd like to use
filters on real time audio
capturing from the microphone.
Is it possible and do you
have a demo for it?
CHRIS WILSON: So real time
filtering of audio input.
Actually, yeah.
There's--
JAN LINDEN: It's one of the--
CHRIS WILSON: That's one of the
effects on the live input
effects demo is an
LFO filter that--
this actually runs it on
a [COMPUTERIZED VOICE]
low frequency oscillator.
You know, actually, telephone
effect is a good one too.
You can tell it's making my
voice a little bit clipped
here but let's flip
to the LFO one.
Well.
The telephone demo is a good
place to start just because
all it does is take the user
input audio and it runs it
through two filters.
One to mask off the low
frequencies and one of mask
off the high frequencies.
And so you only get the middle,
which is typically
what a telephone does.
And the LFO filter, on the other
hand, has this kind of
weird bouncing effect where
it's using a low frequency
oscillator to control the
frequency cut off of a low
pass filter.
So if you listen to yourself
through it, you'll actually
hear it kind of bounce
in and out.
JAN LINDEN: So that shows how
you can vary it in real time.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
And that's actually a
really good topic.
It's one that I'm going to
come up with some more
tutorials on and some videos on,
is doing that sort of real
time effects control using audio
node routing into audio
parameters, which I think is
super powerful and not very
well understood.
In fact, I was talking to one of
my coworkers yesterday who
has done a bunch of Web
Audio stuff and he's
like, you can do that?
I'm like, well yeah.
That's how you do chorus and
flange and these other effects
that you need to have audio rate
controls over things on.
MALE SPEAKER: That's all
the questions we
have time for today.
CHRIS WILSON: OK.
Great.
JAN LINDEN: Excellent.
CHRIS WILSON: Well I think we'll
close there and until
next time, that's Web Audio.
JAN LINDEN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]